حث افاد مراسل الجزيره ان قصفا مدفعيا
عنيفا يستهدف المناطق الشماليه من قطاع
غزه كما افاد مراسلنا بسماع اطلاق نار من
اسلحه رشاشه ثقيله في حي الشجاعيه شرق غزه
هذا وشهد ايضا حي الشيخ رضوان شمال مدينه
غزه اليوم اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالتزامن مع قصف اسرائيلي استهدف المنطقه
المذكوره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للمزيد معنا الان من جباليه شمال قطاع غزه
الصحفي عماد زقوط عماد اهلا بك اذا كيف هو
الوضع في شمال قطاع غزه بشكل عام وفي
جباليه
تحديد نعم ميدانيا الان الاشتباكات اريه
منذ فجر هذا اليوم بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والاليات العسكريه وجنود
الاحتلال على كافه محاور مخيم جبالي
المحور الغربي والمحور الشمالي والمحور
الشرقي وكذلك المحور الجنوبي لمخيم جباليا
داخل ايضا في منطقه جبال البلد هذه اليات
العسكريه التي
تقدمت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه بعد سلسله
عنيفه جدا من الغارات الاسرائيليه من قبل
الطيارات الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت هذه المناطق بمئات الصواريخ
والقدف ايضا من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
على
مستوى الشهداء والوضع الميدان ايضا هنالك
عدد كبير من الشهداء في منطقه جبال البلد
لا تستطيع سياره الاسعاف الوصول اليهم حسب
شهود عيان وكذلك
حسب فارات الاسعاف والمسعفين تحدثوا ان
هنالك ع عشرات الشهداء في مناطق في جبال
البلد وكذلك الجرحى ملقون على الارض لا
تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف الوصول الى هؤلاء
الشهداء وهؤلاء الجرحى في تلك المناطق
التي تتعرض لحتى هذه اللحظه لغارات
اسرائيليه وقصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه التي تطلق عشرات الصواريخ
والقداس تجاه تلك المناطق اذا هذا هو
الواقع الذ الان سكان والاهالي الذين
يعدوا بالالاف في هذه المنطقه تحديدا في
مخيم جباليا هم الان على مساحه اكثر من
كيلو ونصف مربع يتواجدون وفي محيط هذا هذه
المساحه تتواجد الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هنالك اشتباكات عنيفه في
منطقه سل الزعتر وحسب بشع هنالك استهدافات
عده لاعاده الماليات الموجوده في تلك
المنطقه وكذلك
في الجهه الشرقيه هنالك ا اشتباكات
واستهداف لعدد من الاليات العسكريه
وجرافات الاحتلال المتواجده في هذا المكان
لذلك تسمع الان اشتباكات ايضا في المناطق
الغربيه والمناطق الجنوبيه لمخيم جباليا
وفي منطقه جباليا الاليات العسكريه التي
تتقدم في تلك المنطقه هنالك مواجهه عنيفه
بين مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه في تلك
المناطق هذا الواقع ولا يستطيع اي لا توجد
في هذه المنطقه اي من المستشفيات
الفلسطينيه ولا يوجد فقط الا نقطه واحده
نقطه طبيه الان في قلب مخيم جبال وهي تتبع
للهلال الاحمر هذه النقطه الطبيه تواجد
فيها قبي عدد من الاطباء ربما اقل من
ثلاثه اطباء يتواجدون في هذه النقطه
الطبيه التي تقدم الاسعافات
الاوليه النقطه المركزيه للهلال الاحمر
الان هي محاصره من قبل الاليه العسكريه في
شرق جباليه منطقه زمو لا يستطيع اي من
سيارات الاسعاف التحرك من تلك المنطقه حسب
شهود عيان ايضا ما يتعلق بمستشفى العوده
هذا المستشفى الذي تعرض للحصار والاقتحام
من قبل جنود الاحتلال
تعرض الاطقم الطبيه داخل مستشفى العدوان
مستشفى العوده
ل الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه بالضرب وخلع
الملابس وهذا حسب شهود الاعيان انه هذا ما
حدث من تعديد للاطقم الطبيه ميدانيا في
مستشفى العوده الان كل المستشفيات خارج عن
الخدمه لا يوجد اي تحرك ايضا لا تستطيع
سياره الاسعاف التحرك في هذه المناطق التي
تتعرض للعديد من الغارات الاسرائيليه
المتواصله والمكثف من جباليه شمال قطاع
غزه الصحفي عماد زقوط